Vas-y.
C'est bon.
Allez !
En avant monsieur !
Ce n'est pas fini !
Nickel, c'est bien.
Attention !
Ne passez pas là haut,
c'est un barrage obligatoire.
Rapproche ton genou gauche,
donne un coup vers l'arrière.
Voilà.
Vous montez, quand tu touches là,
tu passes de l'autre côté.
Allez ! Allez !
Allez, mon petit !
Saute en avant,
pousse et saute.
Attendez !
Sautes.
C'est bien.
À la tête de cette section,
le sergent-chef Martinez,
36 ans et 12 ans de Légion étrangère.
Saute !
À la fin du mois, on est là.
Il faut s'entraîner.
Passe la main droite
au-dessus et en avant.
Allez !
Allez, pousse-le !
On met les sangles en avant.
Ce sont les hommes de ta section.
On est fier quand la légion
se débrouille bien seule.
Normal, c'est
la deuxième compagnie du trois.
C'est la compagnie
de jungle par excellence.
C'est la seule compagnie professionnelle
de jungle des forces françaises
ici en Guyane.
Ne lâche pas, ne lâche pas.
C'est comme tout dans la vie.
Quand tu arrives
à faire un métier,
n'importe lequel,
quand tu le fais bien, tu es content.
Repos !
Je passe en revue les compagnies
l'une après l'autre.
Les capitaines,
vous me présentez et me suivez.
Les hommes de la section Martinez
vont partir en mission profonde.
Mirza, tu vas découvrir la forêt.
C'est une promenade
pour vous décontracter.
C'est ça.
Le sergent-chef Martinez est espagnol.
Dans sa section, 19 nationalités,
30 hommes venus d'Europe, d'Afrique,
d'Asie.
Ils arrivent.
Ils ont tout gâché,
leur vie de couple,
leur vie financière,
de petit malfrat
d'étudiant remarquable
mais ça ne leur plaisait pas.
Ils reviennent et redémarrent ici.
C'est le seul endroit
au monde où on refait une virginité.
On leur donne notre confiance
après les avoir vérifiés, bien sûr.
On n'admet pas les crimes de sang.
Ça, on le sait parce qu'on a
des renseignements importants.
Dès le moment où on l'a accepté,
on redonne notre confiance
et il redevient un homme
dans toute sa dignité.
C'est pour ça qu'il est là,
prêt à donner sa vie
et quand il donne sa vie, ça évite
à un français peut-être de la donner.
Le transall décolle avec 30 légionnaires
pour Saint Georges,
l'embouchure du fleuve Oyapock.
Ils auront un mois
pour parcourir les 600 kilomètres
de la mission profonde.
Auparavant,
les Marines venaient s'entraîner
avec les légionnaires.
Les Américains ont abandonné, trop dur.
Les hommes
de la section Martinez ont 30 jours
pour aller à 300 kilomètres d'ici,
pour trouver la borne 7
qui marque la frontière
entre la Guyane française et le Brésil.
C'est de la saleté.
Virez-moi cette de pompe
et amenez-moi ces tuyaux.
Il y a un tuyau dedans.
Je vais regarder.
Ne touche pas les rangers avec ça.
Va te laver. Va te laver tout de suite.
Le danger le plus grave, c'est l'eau.
C'est la noyade.
On glisse, on tombe dans les cailloux,
on peut plus sortir.
C'est la flotte, le vrai danger
de la mission profonde fluviale.
C'est pour ça qu'il faut
bien attacher le gilet aux fesses.
Parce que j'ai vu des hommes tomber,
ça a décroché.
Que se passe-t-il là ?
Si tu ne l'attaches
pas aux fesses, après ça tombe.
Il n'existe pas le gilet.
La zone qu'ils pénètrent est interdite.
C'est une réserve naturelle.
Seuls les Indiens ont le droit d'y vivre.
En zone tropicale,
tout change d'un jour à l'autre.
Pour comprendre les rivières,
il faut être né sur leurs rives.
La Légion contacte
des piroguiers indiens ou créoles.
Ils savent lire sur l'eau
les dangers que cache la surface.
À l'avant, le boss man.
D'un coup de pagaie, il met le nez
de la pirogue dans le bon courant.
À l'arrière, le motoriste.
Il ne lâche jamais la poignée des gaz.
Un regard, un geste.
Ils se comprennent.
Un, deux, trois.
Allez-y ! Tirez !
Allez, on continue !
Tirez !
Poussez !
Pendant 30 jours entiers
ces hommes vont macérer dans l'eau,
dans l'humidité,
la moiteur de la forêt.
Ils ne connaîtront plus le sec.
Je n'ai pas accroché.
C'est encore plus dur.
Dans cette section,
on est certainement 30.
Je n'ai pas
encore compté.
Je n'ai aucun problème.
Tout le monde comprend
le français alors ça suffit.
Le légionnaire fait
ce qu'on lui dit, et c'est tout.
L'affaire est bouclée.
On a des ordres
et c'est comme ça !
C'est pour ça
qu'il est légionnaire.
Bolog, en avant.
Débarquez les sacs, amorcez le plein.
On verra demain.
Les sacs à l'abri, on y va.
On verra l'endroit pour le bivouac.
Premier groupe, posez la plaque.
Installation dans un rayon de 20 mètres.
Ils vont passer
leur deuxième nuit dans la forêt.
Dire qu'ils sont trempés en permanence
n'est pas tout à fait exact.
Au bivouac, lorsqu'ils ont installé
leur bâche et tendu leur hamac,
il leur arrive certains soirs
de commencer à sécher.
J'ai connu Djibouti.
Étant enfant, je voyais les légionnaires.
L'idée qu'on avaient c'est
qu'ils cassaient tout, des bagarreurs.
Ça arrivait aussi parfois
que je balance des cailloux
sur les légionnaires.
Voilà, c'est comme ça.
Puis en grandissant,
on a une autre idée.
On voit autrement.
Lorsque je me suis engagé,
au bout de mon premier mois d'instruction,
j'ai reçu mon képi blanc.
C'était quand même quelque chose
de très fort que j'ai ressenti.
Parce que j'étais fier.
J'avais déjà atteint
la première marche de mon but.
J'avais le képi blanc
et j'étais légionnaire.
Pour moi, c'était grandiose.
C'était un rêve.
Enfin, je réussissais
quelque chose de bien.
Au fil de la progression,
la forêt se fait plus dense.
Souvent, elle interdit le passage.
Jette ça.
Peian, débout et tiens la pirogue.
Assieds-toi sur le fut,
pour que la pirogue ne bouge pas.
Allez, bougez vous !
Poussez ce bateau là-bas !
Les tronçonneuses
ne peuvent rien contre celui-là.
Pour passer, il faut utiliser
les grands moyens de l'explosif.
Allez, en avant tronçonneuse !
Coupe un morceau,
qu'on mette le plastic au fond,
Mettez encore quelque chose de large.
Un peu plus si possible.
Donnez-moi deux briquets.
Cherchez-en deux, secs, qui fonctionnent.
J'en ai un.
-Combien faut-il ?
-Il faut 11,7 kilogrammes.
On met 14, tu vas voir.
Pour 11,7 on met 14 kilogrammes.
-C'est bon ? On peut commencer à bourrer ?
-Oui commencez.
Commencez déjà à bourrer.
Ne reste ici
que la pirogue de commandement.
Ludwig, minimum 500 mètres d'ici.
Allez, en avant.
On va faire demi-tour ici.
Quand j'allume, c'est parti.
Mets-les à l'intérieur.
C'est bon comme ça.
Ça va faire
une grande explosion mon ami.
Surtout ne pas prendre de risque.
Les pirogues sont envoyées
500 mètres en arrière.
Ça a explosé.
La force de la Légion,
il n'y a pas de super-hommes.
Ils sont tous pareils.
L'atout de la Légion
ce n'est pas d'être plus beau,
plus fort, plus costaud ou
courir plus vite. Ça n'a rien à voir.
Ce sont des gens
qui ont eu une expérience avant,
plus que militaire.
On peut trouver tout à la légion.
On peut se trouver isolés en Yougoslavie,
ou n'importe où,
il y aura toujours un homme
qui était cuisinier à Paris
mais on ne sait pas.
On va manger comme des rois.
Pareil dans d'autres cadres.
Pour faire la maison,
un homme dira que son père était maçon
et qu'il sait faire.
C'est lui qui va commander.
Les accidents ce sont
les coups de chaleur et coupe-coupe.
Alors faites attention
à ce coupe-coupe.
Mettez la dragonne le soir.
Avec la fatigue, on se coupe.
Il n'y a plus d'eau,
ce n'est pas dangereux.
Maintenant,
faites-moi le plein des bidons.
La baignade et l'eau
à souhait sont finis.
Remplissez les deux bidons.
Dès maintenant, mettez bien la pilule.
On la mettait
mais mettez-en dans les bidons.
Enlevez le gilet, mettez-le ici, groupés.
Débarquez les sacs
à mon commandement maintenant.
L'Oyapock n'est plus qu'un ruisseau,
pas un mais des ruisseaux.
L'eau coule partout et les pirogues
ne peuvent pas aller plus loin.
À partir d'ici, ils n'auront plus
que jambes et épaules.
Pendant trois semaines,
ils porteront matériel et nourriture.
Vérifiez bien maintenant les trois.
Tout le matériel dont on a besoin.
Tous les jours, vous savez ce qu'il y a
et il n'y a pas de problèmes.
Chacun va porter près de 50 kilos
de 10 à 12 heures par jour.
Pour se diriger dans la forêt,
il n'y a que la boussole et la carte.
Les satellites leur permettent
de connaître leur position exacte
grâce au GPS.
Mon métier dans le civil,
c'était représentant en immobilier.
La société pour laquelle
je travaillais a dû fermer
donc je cherchais quelque chose
pour une sécurité de l'emploi.
On ne demande
pas pourquoi ils sont là.
Je n'ai jamais demandé pourquoi.
Je ne veux pas savoir
pourquoi ils sont ici.
C'est leur problème.
Je n'aime pas qu'on me demande
pourquoi je suis là. C'est pareil.
Bien, mettez la colonne par un.
Prêts à parrtir, en avant.
Le point clé,
qui est le dernier aujourd'hui ?
Al baw,
que le topofil reste en place, d'accord ?
Laissez trois
ou quatre mètres entre vous.
Les coupe-coupe,
la dragonne. En avant, c'est parti.
Ils se trouvent très précisément
à 29 kilomètres de la borne sept.
Vingt-neuf kilomètres à vol d'oiseau.
Aucun repère dans la forêt.
Parfois les derniers sont
à plus de 200 mètres des premiers.
Souvent,
on ne voit pas celui qui précède.
Ici, tout est vert et dense.
Alors, on déroule le topofil.
Un fil de coton, le fil d'Ariane
qui permettra
de ne pas s'égarer dans le labyrinthe.
Attends. Ça va ?
Le roulé-boulé. Calme-toi.
Ce n'est pas encore un saut en parachute.
Ce n'est pas aussi dur qu'on croyait.
Non attends.
On va attendre
que tout le monde descende.
Viva la Légion !
Allez, tout droit.
L'homme de tête défriche
avec un coupe-coupe
en suivant les avis du deuxième,
qui a les yeux rivés sur sa boussole.
C'est bien comme ça, tout droit.
Décale vers la gauche légèrement.
Oui. C'est ça.
Tout droit,
c'est bien. Allez-y.
Derrière, quelques autres élargissent
et marquent le passage.
Le rythme, c'est 40 minutes sac au dos,
puis un arrêt de 10 minutes.
Une douzaine de fois par jour,
il faut hisser les 50 kilos
sur les épaules, repartir et tenir
jusqu'à la nouvelle pause.
Vingt-trois kilomètres en France,
sur un chemin carrossable,
ça fait six heures de marche.
Ici, tu as vu ?
En plus,
on ne sait même pas où on est.
J'ai vraiment l'impression
qu'on ne va pas droit.
On va droit. Il arrive.
Alors Buron, c'est comment?
Montez un peu
et posez les sacs.
Attention au topofil Batek.
Posez à gauche.
On a calculé à combien ?
Mille-huit-cent
C'est le topofil
qui donne la distance parcourue,
1800 mètres en quatre heures.
Le rythme est bon, 400 mètres à l'heure.
On devait faire
cinq kilomètres. Ça fait mal.
Je sais,
mais ce n'est pas grave.
Ça fait partie du métier.
Sinon, ça marche assez aujourd'hui.
On a une bonne cadence.
Bonne mise en jambes,
réveil musculaire sympathique.
Le premier, c'est
pour chauffer la machine.
La machine est chaude, ça va aller.
Ça va.
À la Légion
la première chose qu'on apprend,
c'est la discipline et la camaraderie.
On vit ensemble.
On se fatigue et on mange ensemble,
C'est mieux qu'on reste
toujours amis ensemble.
La discipline est la base.
Sans discipline
dans une section, tu n'arrives à rien.
En particulier dans la Légion.
Nivaquine à la main !
Prenez cette pilule.
En avant.
Bon, à partir de maintenant,
rassemblement à 6h30, réveil.
Départ à 7h30, d'accord ?
Ça fait 15 minutes de plus.
À 7h30, tout le monde est là.
Comme vous êtes fatigués,
on laisse 15 minutes de plus.
C'est compris ?
Gorny, écoute bien ici.
On a fait
deux jours et demi de marche.
On commence à être fatigués.
On a marché presque plat.
Aujourd'hui,
c'est le jour le plus difficile.
C'est le plus vallonné.
On a fait déjà
presque 14 kilomètres topo.
Il reste
16 kilomètres avant la borne.
Les commandos, les petites plaies,
soignez-les.
Parce que sinon on n'y arrivera pas.
Troisième groupe sac à dos.
Maintenant,
la progression sera encore plus lente,
mais il faut aller le plus droit possible
malgré le relief et les obstacles.
Ils appellent cela l'azimut brutal.
Doucement !
Il faut
être tout le temps en éveil,
faire attention
à l'endroit où on va poser le pied.
S'accrocher
à une branche peut être fatal.
-C'est sur la feuille.
-Sur la branche.
C'est un fer de lance.
C'est dangereux.
-Il ne va pas attaquer ?
-Non c'est bon, on passe ici.
Non c'est mieux par là.
Trois jours, quatre heures maximum.
Ils rencontrent très peu d'animaux.
Les gros vont loin devant eux,
Il reste les insectes.
Malgré les habits, ils sont dévorés
par les moustiques et les fourmis.
Posez les sacs, là.
On sait parfaitement où on est.
Il nous manque environ 14 kilomètres.
On a fait deux kilomètres,
il reste deux kilomètres
pour aller au bivouac.
Entourés comme ça,
ce sont des gros pitons.
C'est pourquoi on monte,
et on va descendre.
À partir de là,
si on continue le même azimut,
à un moment,
on va faire 500 mètres de marécages.
On va traverser des criques,
il y a de l'eau partout.
-C'est ça les criques ?
-Non, les noires.
Vous voyez les criques comment ?
Parce que je suis le chef.
Regarde, tous les petits pointillés,
ce sont des criques.
Les criques, ce sont les ruisseaux.
Regarde.
Là, il y a de l'eau.
Un cassoulet Bel Abbès.
À midi, la pause repas.
Au menu des rations de combat,
navarin d'agneau, paëlla ou cassoulet.
Avec celui-là,
tu peux manger n'importe quoi.
Si vous voulez, il est là.
S'il te plaît, passe-moi le Tabasco.
C'est une vie d'homme.
On vit entre hommes,
on a des blagues d'hommes.
On a notre propre langage.
On vit à côté.
La vie du légionnaire et la vie civile,
ce sont deux routes différentes.
Ayant connu dans le civil une vie,
un peu plus,
je dirais, libre.
Là, au départ on a un peu du mal
à se mettre dans le moule.
Il y a des choses qui sont un peu
un peu dures à comprendre.
Ce n'est pas évident parfois,
mais le travail, c'est le travail.
Si tu es content, tu restes.
Sinon tu pars. Ce n'est pas un secret.
Après la boue, la sueur,
tous les soirs, il faut se laver.
Un plaisir, mais aussi
une obligation pour éviter les infections.
Il faut surtout
prendre soin de ses pieds.
Un pied blessé dans la forêt,
c'est un désastre.
À force de macérer
dans les rangers trempées,
les problèmes commencent.
Le capitaine médecin
Dampierre est là pour soigner
et prendre les décisions médicales.
Il y a un pour demain matin.
S'ils ont mal, ils vous demanderont.
D'accord, et ce soir ?
-Ce soir, ils prendront Fucidine.
Là où c'est infecté. Attends.
-Il faut bien masser.
-Ça te fait le plus mal où ?
Le talon et ici.
C'est surtout là.
Le caporal Jolibois
a attendu trop longtemps
avant d'admettre qu'il avait mal.
Là où la peau est enlevée,
vous lavez aussi.
Ailleurs, tu mets de la Biafine.
Le médecin militaire est là parfois
pour déceler aussi la maladie
que le légionnaire
ne veut pas montrer.
Parce qu'il veut porter son sac.
Il ne veut pas
que ses camarades le fasse.
Il ne dira pas s'il a mal à la tête,
de la fièvre, mal au pied, au dos.
Si on veut pouvoir
maintenir l'ensemble du personnel
jusqu'à l'arrivée de la mission,
il faudra qu'on repère
les petits signes qui montrent
que celui-là va mal.
Jeune engagé volontaire
sans képi blanc,
on avait déjà
l'esprit de s'entraider.
De se dire : "Tu tiendras,
on va te porter, tu viendras avec nous."
"On ne te laissera là."
Il y a toute sorte. Il ne faut pas dire
qu'un légionnaire c'est ça.
C'est peut-être
un état d'esprit comme ça.
Ils ne sont pas tous ainsi.
Il y en a qui veulent fuir en hélicoptère.
Il y en a toujours.
La plupart du temps
c'est ça. Aujourd'hui, Ratzer est malade.
Il a mal au pied
mais il va marcher demain.
C'est comme ça et c'est tout.
Il n'y a pas de paresseux.
On va de l'avant.
Il n'y a pas de secret.
On est arrivé
de bonne heure aujourd'hui.
Le soleil n'est pas couché,
on mange déjà.
On mange bien ce soir.
Tu as mal aux pieds ?
Les champignons sont sortis ?
C'est bon ? Allez !
On ne cause pas le soir.
On arrive tellement fatigués,
on veut juste manger et se coucher.
Demain,
dès que le jour se lève, c'est parti.
Réveil à 6h30, prêts à partir à 7h30.
Premier groupe, on y va à 8h00.
Allez, on y va.
On s'en va d'ici.
En fin de journée, Martinez
ne comprend plus sa carte.
Il ne trouve pas
de lieu pour le bivouac.
C'est bon.
- On n'est pas encore arrivé chef.
- Ce n'est pas possible !
Il va bientôt faire nuit.
Il faut une crique,
l'eau propre pour la toilette,
pour les bidons,
mais surtout pas un marécage.
On n'est pas encore arrivé.
Ce n'est pas possible.
C'est toujours pareil,
on le voit sur la carte.
On était ici.
On montait juste
et on arrivait là.
Il n'y a pas d'eau ici, c'est celui-là ?
Ce n'est pas possible.
- Al Baw ?
- Chef !
Combien de mètres
depuis la dernière fois ?
C'est bon, laisse tomber.
- J'ai raté le compteur.
- Laisse tomber !
- On peut descendre ?
- Oui, on peut.
On descend par la rivière.
On y va.
On va descendre pile par la rivière.
On va suivre la rivière. En avant !
Cette rivière est
un des innombrables ruisseaux boueux
qu'ils croisent tous les jours
et qui leur permet d'avoir de l'eau.
Ceux qui ont besoin de soins.
Ça ne s'améliore pas beaucoup
parce que ça c'est infecté.
La veille,
il n'y en avait qu'un.
Ce soir, ils sont dix.
Toi, tu boîtes.
Dix hommes
sur 30 avec des pieds blessés.
Pour le sergent-chef Martinez,
la grosse tuile.
Toi et ceux
de ton groupe qui peuvent marcher.
C'est qui là-bas ?
Ceux qui ont mal au pied,
dans le hamac, tout de suite !
Je n'en ai rien à faire
- Bolog ?
- Oui !
En avant !
Attention, tous ces hommes
chez toi qui sont malades,
restent toute la journée
dans le hamac, les pieds au sec.
Allez, en avant !
Ceux qui ne font rien,
mettez-vous en tenue de sport.
Ne bougez pas de ce hamac.
Parce que sinon, on n'y arrivera jamais.
Si ça continue ainsi, quand on arrivera
plus personne ne pourra marcher.
Ça m'arriver à moi, toi,
au capitaine, à tout le monde !
Cette saleté !
Neuf sur 30,
ce n'est pas mal.
Non, 9.
Mazur 10, et Mckenna 11.
Vous aussi, 12.
Douze sur 30,
c'est près de la moitié.
Ne me dis pas
que ce sont les kilomètres qu'on a faits,
ou que ce sont les rangers,
qu'on n'a pas ciré les pompes.
Ce n'est pas ça.
Je n'ai jamais vu ça.
C'est un nouveau champignon.
Ça serait dû à quoi ?
Ça serait dû au fait
qu'ils ont toujours les mêmes chaussettes.
Ils ne n'enlèvent pas.
Je ne sais pas.
Trois heures du matin.
La loi des séries, le légionnaire Urcace
fait une crise de paludisme.
À cet endroit, c'est délicat.
Ils ont
un traitement lourd, l'Alfan.
Normalement, on ne l'administre
qu'à l'hôpital
avec une assistance cardio vasculaire.
Évacuer le malade signifierait déblayer
2500 mètres carrés de forêt,
toute une journée de travail
pour qu'un hélicoptère se pose.
Réveil !
- Réveil.
- Bonjour.
Ils sont toujours
à 10 kilomètres de la borne
et il ne leur reste
que trois jours pour la trouver.
Écoutez une minute.
Urcace fait une crise de paludisme
Vous savez qu'avant de partir
de Kourou, il était négatif à ça.
Personne n'est à l'abri.
Peut-être ce soir
je ferai une crise. Je n'en sais rien.
À partir de maintenant,
prenez-moi cette pilule.
S'il vous plaît.
Aujourd'hui, on reste ici.
Vous les malades,
Le bain c'est 30 minutes.
C'est tout le pied.
Dès maintenant,
plus de soucis.
Maintenant, c'est en avant.
Je ne veux pas plaintes.
C'est en avant.
Depuis deux jours on a fait un effort.
Alors vous exécutez les ordres.
Allez là-bas
laver ces pieds comme il faut.
Ce soir vous les lavez correctement.
Il n'y a pas de : "Non, je n'ai pas."
Le capitaine
médecin a dit de le faire.
Sinon,
on ne s'en sortira pas.
S'il faut faire une zone de poser,
je vous montrerais le travail.
Après, pas de mal de pieds.
Tout le monde en rangers, en avant.
Tout le monde a compris ?
Charlie, 12 personnels
avec derme abrasion des pieds,
probable infection
non mycosique, sensible au KMnO4,
en 48 heures, dont cinq personnels
impossible de marcher ce jour.
Ce message en morse est juste
pour rendre compte.
Ce n'est pas
un appel au secours.
Avec cette journée de repos
forcé, Martinez est sûr que demain,
ils pourront repartir.
Allez, on y va.
Vous marchez trop groupés !
Rivière coupes, ils ne coupent pas.
Avance un peu,
les autres sont trop groupés.
Un mètre l'un derrière l'autre.
Il y en a deux pour couper,
avancez un peu plus.
On y va.
Ce n'est pas la peine
que tu coupes et l'autre rien.
Il n'y a plus de choix,
il faut avancer.
Urcace aussi,
malgré sa crise de paludisme.
D'après le GPS,
La borne est à quelques pas.
Combien on a dit l'azimut ? 4000 ?
Quatre-mille.
- C'est 650.
- Six-cent-cinquante ? En avant.
Maintenant,
fais-moi un autoroute aller-retour.
Mon capitaine si tout va bien,
On est là à 10h30 maximum.
Si tout va bien,
que la borne n'a pas été bougé.
Si tout va bien mon capitaine,
on ramène la borne numéro sept.
Dans le sac à dos.
C'est Urcace qui va la ramener.
On a fait combien ?
Deux-cent-quatre-vingt-cinq,
300 et 200 mètres.
La rivière c'est celui-là.
C'est là-bas, je ne me trompe pas.
J'ai dit quoi ?
La borne est à 300 mètres.
En avant. Comptez
300 mètres à partir de maintenant.
Trois-cents mètres à 4500.
C'est une clairière. On continue.
Continue tout droit.
Viens par là.
Entre à l'intérieur.
Prends ce petit chemin.
Il y a la boue et de la merde.
Entre à l'intérieur.
Vois,
c'est une zone de poser.
Normalement la borne est là.
Fais un chemin
tout droit vers là-bas.
Ratzer.
Tu vois une clairière ?
Pas de clairière ?
Une clairière !
Quelque chose de clair sans bambous !
Fais attention au coupe-coupe.
Tu as vu
toute la merde qu'a mon ami ?
Toujours ces bambous !
Si la borne est là,
difficile de la trouver.
Ce n'est pas possible le désordre !
Pour moi c'est la zone de poser.
Ça c'est le nord.
C'est la rivière et la borne est là.
Allez, oh !
Venez ici, tous ! Rivière, viens ici !
Rivière !
On l'a trouvée !
Le GPS ne donne rien !
On arrive ! On arrive !
La tête du GPS, n'importe quoi !
Attends !
J'arrive là.
C'est dommage.
Ne bouge pas, où êtes vous ?
Tu es à côté de la borne ?
Silence ! Calmez-vous !
Mettez-vous autour de la borne.
Qu'il nous filme !
C'est l'homme qui l'a trouvée.
- Le première classe Terkiev.
- Terkiev.
Fais le tour,
qu'ils voient la grosse scheisse.
Difficile de trouver
cette borne au milieu de la forêt.
On est vraiment bons.
On est vraiment merveilleux.
On a trouvé cette borne.
C'est bien Terkiev. Tu as vu ?
C'est le deuxième compagnie.
Troisième R.E.I.
Il n'y a pas la troisième.
Adjudant Pellegrin.
Derrière la borne, la France.
De ce côté-ci, le Brésil.
La découverte de la borne
ne veut pas dire repos.
Ils doivent aménager
la zone de poser pour l'hélicoptère,
2500 mètres carrés de forêt
doivent être dégagés.
C'est une tradition
dans la Légion de toujours bâtir.
On ne peut pas rester couché
toute la journée à ne rien faire.
C'est une tradition.
Le numéro trois du régiment,
leur colonel, sera dans l'hélicoptère.
Ils faut l'accueillir,
comme le veut la tradition,
en construisant
un carbet où prendre le repas.
Il se passe quoi ?
Vous n'avez pas de gants ?
Attention aux mains.
Urcace, sortez deux housses de bidons.
Sortez deux housses
et donnez-les à Ratzer.
Tu sais
à quoi sert la housse ? Regarde.
Tu vois ?
Il y a toujours
des gants de fortune.
C'est bon Urcace, on en a deux.
C'est bon, allez.
Il faut vraiment
important de boucher les trous.
S'il flotte, l'homme ici sera mal.
Tant pis pour lui.
Il ne faut pas se mettre là,
mettez vous ici.
On va faire le repas pendant deux heures.
Que ce soit au moins couvert.
J'espère que demain
il fera le même temps qu'aujourd'hui.
Si demain c'est
le même temps qu'aujourd'hui,
ce sera
parfait pour se poser
Demain il va pleuvoir, tu verras.
C'est bon pour les espaces verts.
J'ai envie d'enlever tout ça
et l'emmener chez mon père.
À la campagne.
Couper un morceau de terre.
Ce n'est pas beau ?
Depuis, ils ont dévoré
leurs dernières rations. Tous ont faim.
Ils s'occupent pour ne pas y penser.
-J'ai le hachis parmentier.
-Je le déteste.
Idiot.
Le hachis parmentier est dégoutant chef.
Tu n'as rien eu,
demande du café au capitaine.
Il y a du café chef.
On boit un café TAF ici.
En avant !
Je dois me gratter.
Gratte-toi.
Allez ! Un petit café TAF.
-C'est tiède ?
-Non, il est chaud.
Il est magnifique.
Par contre,
ne me brulez pas la table je vous prie.
Non, on sèche.
Il est loin. Il n'entend pas.
Il est à 10 heures.
- Vous le voyez ?
- Pas encore, attends.
Il est à midi.
Vertical.
- Martinez, bonjour.
- Mon colonel !
- Ça peut aller.
- Ça peut aller ?
Pas totalement,
mais ça va.
Le repas a failli rester.
Ça aurait été dur.
On était déjà juste
au niveau de la gamelle.
Ça peut aller mon comandant.
C'est bien pour le moment.
- On a tous les pieds explosés.
- Il faut voir leurs pieds.
Il y en a trois qui partent.
Pendant deux jours, il y a sept
qui n'ont pas bougé des hamacs.
Vous avez été longtemps dans l'eau ?
C'est la peau qui taille la route.
Le soir, on a fait des bains.
Ça a cicatrisé en un jour.
C'est impossible !
Il n'y a plus rien en un jour.
Ils ne peuvent pas marcher.
Présentez, armes !
MP 33 rassemblez sous les armes,
six sous-officiers,
20 caporaux et légionnaires.
À vos ordres mon colonel.
À mon commandement,
portez, armes ! Repos.
Dans l'hélicoptère,
des bières et du rhum
pour saluer la découverte de la borne.
Surtout le ravitaillement.
De quoi remettre
les sacs de chacun à 50 kilos
pour repartir dans l'autre sens.
Ils n'en sont
qu'à la moitié de leur mission.
On a dormi en haut, aux trois-sauts.
On est reparti
vers la crique Primavera.
- Tu as fait quoi, un schulz ?
- Oui.
Jolibois.
Vatek.
Vatek, tu m'agaces !
Les relevés bancaires, tout va bien.
Vacances MP 33.
Il n'y a pas de mail,
mais il y a des douleurs aux pieds.
C'est magnifique.
Je tombe sur du jambon à la vanille.
Rien à dire.
Mon capitaine, vous ne voulez pas
un thon à la catalane ?
C'est vachement bien.
Il se réserve.
Manger
une côte de bœuf, c'est nouveau.
Je n'ai pas terminé.
- Mercredi, tu n'avais plus de ration ?
- C'était Chili con carne je crois.
Bonne chance
pour le retour, on vous attend à Kourou.
Pour arroser ça
et préparer Camerone.
La section !
Présentez armes !
Terkiev, rentre un peu.
Laissez la place à Terkiev.
Mettez derrière Stopka et Gorny.
C'est bon.
C'est bon comme ça ?
Tout le monde est là ?
Allez, faites un effort pour la photo.
La Légion, c'est notre patrie.
C'est notre famille.
Je le comprends.
Comme une famille.
On est entre nous sur le terrain.
On dirait un papa et 30 fils.
La patrie,
c'est là où on est né.
Ça n'empêche pas que,
je parle toujours au niveau personnel,
d'être fier
de faire ce qu'on fait.
Avec la famille qu'on a.
Soldats de France.
Soldats du pays.
Camerone, la fête de la légion.
Camerone c'est tous les 30 avril.
Miss Képi blanc Camerone 1999.
Camerone, c'était le 30 avril 1863.
La France de Napoléon III
faisait la guerre au Mexique.
Soixante-quatre hommes de la Légion
étrangère tenaient Camerone,
2000 mexicains l'encerclait.
Pendant neuf heures,
les légionnaires tombèrent.
Au bout des neuf heures,
il n'en restait que cinq.
Les mexicains, ahuris par leur courage,
acceptèrent de les laisser aller
comme ils le voudraient.
Pas comme des vaincus.
Avec leurs armes et leurs blessés.
C'est à Camerone qu'est née leur légende.